avec nous aujourd'hui pour ce club des
territoires spécial grand débat sur la
question de l'immigration trois
sénateurs bonjour Jérôme Durin merci
d'être avec nous c'est Nathan socialiste
de Saône-et-Loire Xavier jacoubelly
bonjour merci d'être là sénateur RDPI
renaissance des Hauts-de-Seine c'est le
groupe des sénateurs de la majorité
présidentielle et Jérôme Bachard bonjour
sénateur les républicains de loi merci à
tous les trois d'être là évidemment Alex
nous a rejoint grand débat donc avec
vous sur l'immigration Elisabeth borne
sera devant le Sénat cet après-midi pour
présenter les grandes lignes de son
projet de loi un texte qu'elle dit
équilibré entre humanité et fermeté vous
nous direz ce que vous en pensez et si
un compromis est possible on va voir
dans quelques instants les grandes
lignes de ce texte avec vous Alex mais
d'abord un mot messieurs avant de parler
du fond sur la méthode venir débattre
devant vous cet après-midi comme va le
faire Elisabeth avant même la
présentation du texte en conseil des
ministres c'est une bonne chose j'aime
bien écouter c'est un tour de chauffe
donc si ça me permet effectivement un
débat
utile c'est bon à prendre
ça permettra peut-être de préciser un
centre de choses qui ne sont pas encore
tout à fait claires dans les quelques
éléments dont nous disposons donc soyons
ouverts à ce stade de la réflexion
du travail on va évidemment parler sur
la méthode Jérôme de chasse ça vous va
cette méthode c'est un signe d'ouverture
envers le Parlement c'est occupe le
terrain
c'est plus
que je vous dise on a des ministres qui
ont fait des déclarations deux ministres
Gérald Darmanin mise à l'intérieur
Olivier du socle en charge du travail
et derrière
cheat rien un texte sur l'immigration
qui devait venir en septembre
puis en janvier
puis en mars comme disait Jean-François
Copé avant c'est comme Pierre traite
plus c'est plus en avance mais on recule
quoi c'est donc c'est peut-être une
étape c'est peut-être pour nous dire
qu'on va encore repousser je ne sais pas
on va l'écouter
Xavier
c'était une promesse de du président de
la République de pouvoir faire un débat
sur l'immigration un débat annuel sur
l'immigration c'était d'ailleurs une
demande de l'opposition et je crois de
l'opposition LR donc on répond
favorablement aux demandes de
l'opposition donc je pense que mon
collègue devrait être content et puis
c'est ça va aussi dans le bon sens
c'est-à-dire que il y a une concertation
il y a une présentation d'un projet
ensuite il y a la concertation il y a le
débat au Parlement et ensuite on passera
effectivement sur l'examen du texte avec
les différentes les différents apports
des groupes politiques je pense que
c'est ça aussi la nouvelle méthode qui
est prenait par le Président de la
République depuis mai dernier ça vous
fait rire
il y a pas de méthode honnêtement on
sort de la loi de finance vous savez on
avait à peine voté la loi de finances au
Sénat une demi-heure après il y avait
200 millions de plus pour ceci le
lendemain matin il y a plus pour cela
donc on voit bien qu'on n'a pas changé
de méthode en vérité on fait ce qu'on
veut
par contre vous vous avez pas changé de
méthode c'est toujours la posture quoi
non mais en fait j'ai demandé un débat
qu'on met en place mais par contre vous
n'êtes pas content parce qu'on met en
place le débat avant la loi donc la
possibilité de nous expliquer la posture
c'est celle de déclarer très fermement
il y aura une loi sur l'immigration en
septembre non en octobre déjà parce que
septembre on était pas septembre on
devait commencer d'ailleurs au mois
d'octobre au Sénat par la loi
immigration effectivement vous avez
raison parce que accessoirement il y a
eu d'autres textes qui étaient peut-être
plus important pour notre pays et donc
ça a été décalé d'abord en janvier et
effectivement avec un débat qui est
prévu en décembre donc nous aurons le
texte à partir de fin janvier début
février a priori on devrait s'en
remettre on verra Gérald Darmanin avait
dit que la locmin à l'autre
programmation du ministère d'intérieur
était une priorité puisque c'était 15
milliards pour les forces de l'or
visiblement c'est pas votre avis Jérôme
Bachard on va pas refaire ce débat juste
29e loi asile et immigration depuis 1980
c'est une loi qui est vraiment
nécessaire vous aviez je pense que
contrairement aux 28e enfin 28 autres
lois sur l'immigration celle-ci elle est
équilibrée c'est à dire que on parle
effectivement de la question de la
régulation de l'immigration de faire en
sorte d'avoir une fermeté aussi pour
ceux qui n'ont pas vocation à être sur
le territoire mais faire en sorte de
régulariser de faire en sorte de mieux
intégrer ceux qui ont vocation à être
sur le territoire de faciliter aussi les
demandeurs les demandes d'asile pardon
et puis la question qui est pour moi
indispensable c'est la question de
l'intégration par le travail et
l'intégration par le français quand on
voit que 25% aujourd'hui des des
ressortissants étrangers qui ont leur
titre de séjour ne parlent pas français
je pense qu'il y a un problème
d'intégration par la suite et donc
aujourd'hui il y a une obligation
uniquement de suivre un cursus de
environ 600 heures de français mais il y
a pas une obligation de résultats là on
passerait et on se mettrait d'ailleurs
en cohérence avec nos voisins européens
notamment l'Allemagne l'Italie les
Pays-Bas avec une obligation d'avoir un
minimum requis de français parce que
c'est par la langue qu'on se peut
s'intégrer dans un pays
là-dessus sur la nécessité de la loi
gérandir sur la nécessité de
l'intégration oui
sur le terme du débat on voit qu'on
reste quand même toujours dans des
choses très macronistes très en même
temps ces binaire c'est gentil avec les
gentils méchants avec les méchants la
fermeté l'humanité et le diable il se le
jugera dans les détails comment ça se
passe dans les préfectures comment ça se
passe sur la liste des métiers en
tension quels sont les processus
réellement proposés pour l'intégration
c'est ça qui va falloir rentrer dans le
détail de ce texte Alex puisque on va
voir quelles sont les grandes lignes
avec vous de ce projet de loi en tout
cas ce qu'on en connaît avec une
dimension économique et sociale dont on
parle beaucoup vous d'abord mais oui on
parle beaucoup de cette création d'un
nouveau titre de séjour de métier en
tension mais que le gouvernement veut
créer et qui permettra de régulariser
les travailleurs sans papier les
orienter dans les secteurs avec beaucoup
d'emplois non pourvu en France alors il
existe une liste actuellement de métiers
en tension mais le gouvernement pourrait
élargir à la restauration la petite
enfance le bâtiment la propreté et la
logistique on va écouter la première
ministre Elisabeth borne la semaine
dernière à l'Assemblée nationale sur
cette régularisation des travailleurs
sans papiers
de
la restitution irrégulière présente sur
notre sol depuis des années et qui
travaille depuis longtemps et avant que
l'extrême droite ne tente une nouvelle
manipulation je le redis il ne s'agit en
aucun cas d'une régularisation massive
ni de laisser penser que la
régularisation serait la réponse aux
tensions sur le marché du travail il
s'agit de régulariser certaines
personnes qui de contribuent depuis
longtemps à la richesse nationale mais
qui subissent parfois des conditions de
travail indignes et restent enfermés
dans un statut précaire et puis l'autre
objectif de ce texte c'est d'accélérer
le traitement des demandes d'asile une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français sera délivré des le premier
rejet de la demande d'asile mais il y
aura toujours la possibilité de faire
appel pour suspendre cette décision
d'expulsion et puis toujours pour
accélérer le traitement de la demande
d'asile et bien la Cour nationale du
droit d'asile qui prend les décisions en
appel sera déployée dans plusieurs
régions et plus uniquement à Paris et
puis Alex ce texte a aussi pour objectif
de faciliter les pour l'instant
seulement 10% des obligations de quitter
le territoire français sont
effectivement exécutés c'est assez peu
et Gérald de Darmanin veut muscler sa
politique d'expulsion d'abord en donnant
la priorité à l'expulsion des étrangers
délinquants en simplifiant le traitement
des contentieux quatre recours contre
une expulsion seront désormais possible
au lieu de 12 et puis en cas de menaces
de troubles à l'ordre public à certaines
protections contre l'expulsion se
relever pour certaines personnes par
exemple qui résident en France depuis
plus de 10 ans ou qui sont arrivés en
France durant leur enfance ou qui sont
mariés à un français
c'est un texte pour qui équilibré entre
humanité et fermeté comme le ventre le
gouvernement bah non pourquoi
la fermeté la fermeté elle peut se faire
d'ores et déjà avec les textes existants
je vais vous donner un seul exemple et
aussi entre de ce qui ne faut pas faire
moi j'étais très content que la France
je le dis très simplement à accueil le
chien de Viking pas de problème
là-dessus on va pas lisser c'est
absolument horrible je suis absolument
scandalisé du traitement qui a été fait
après de ces migrants ils sont partis à
la rue les tribunaux n'ont pas pu juger
d'arcade etc et ainsi de suite on voit
bien que on ne sait pas déployer les
moyens qu'il faut lorsqu'on veut traiter
à ce sujet exceptionnel et bien là c'est
à peu près la même chose vous
n'arriverez pas à traiter les choses de
cette façon vous savez j'étais
auditionné j'ai travaillé à l'époque
pour la seule se rappeler Adoma et qui
est le premier
gestionnaire de demandeurs d'asile en
France
à l'époque Philippe d'allier nous
interrogeait savoir qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire sur la demande d'asile etc on en
est toujours au même point en vérité et
les nouveaux les nouveaux textes ne
changent rien ça fait des années des
années que on revanche ce qu'on ne fait
pas c'est revoir qui a le droit de
demander l'asile car la vérité c'est que
la France est aujourd'hui embolisée par
des faux demandeurs d'asile c'est à peu
près deux tiers des rejets ça doit être
ça les chiffres je regarde laisse
regarder mes collègues et parce que il y
a près de la moitié qui n'ont rien à
faire avec une demande d'asile c'est
juste une demande d'immigration illégale
et on s'occupe pendant cela de deux ans
trois ans on touche l'équivalent la
location je vais dire d'attente pour le
pendant ce temps-là on est parfois dans
des filières très organisées je pense à
Tchétchénie par exemple les tchétchène
une filière tchétchène de en France de
finalement de malfaisants qui prend
demande
acide et des bouteilles au bout de deux
ans et passe les clés de la Mercedes sur
le parking du CADA
à son successeur Jérôme Durand et un peu
même question que Jérôme Bacher dire qui
on veut qui on peut accueillir et dire
qui on ne veut pas et qui on ne peut pas
accueillir c'est comme ça qu'elle les
avait borne résume ce texte et la
philosophie du gouvernement sur
l'immigration c'est une bonne
philosophie moi je pense qu'on ne peut
pas avoir une bonne politique
d'immigration
si elle n'est pas adossée un vrai projet
républicain et si on pose pas les bases
politiques au sens
républicaine de ce débat c'est-à-dire
que est-ce que la France est un pays qui
est heureux d'accueillir de nouvelles
populations qui est capable de les
intégrer qui est capable d'en faire des
français tant qu'on pose pas ces
questions et qu'on reste sur des
amalgames on a entendu en séance au
Sénat la semaine dernière au chien de
vikings
réfugiés terroriste Bataclan bon si si
le débat c'est ça au secours au secours
dans la bouche d'Elisabeth band c'est
pas ça puisqu'elle dit il faut il faut
voir qui on accueille il faut mieux
accueillir et voir
quelle intégration
c'est le sujet et comment mes mains
comment on met fin au gâchis ces
questions d'occf non exécutés c'est un
gâchis mens pour nos forces de sécurité
intérieure on balade des gens d'un bout
de la France à l'autre bout on les
emmène en crabe on les sort du crabe
pour les emmener à l'avion qui rentre
pas il repartent encra tout ça est
minable et puis je termine sur la
question du travail moi j'avais fait une
proposition de loi ravacley pour
intégrer des jeunes majeurs passés par
les social à l'enfance
pour obtenir la régularisation de de son
apprenti mais quel gâchis il y a des
gens qui travaillent dans des métiers
réellement en tension 8000 postes dans
la boulangerie justement et pourtant
je vous laisse répondre sur la
philosophie Xavier iacovelli puisque
Jérôme Durand et Jean Bachar sont
d'accord pour dire il faut poser la
question de l'accueil républicain
je suis d'accord aussi avec Jérôme
Durance sur la question du du gâchis et
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que on veut
faire un texte qui puisse corriger un
certain nombre de défauts dans notre loi
et notamment sur la question de
l'intégration quand on sait aujourd'hui
que dans notre pays la question de la
restauration la question du bâtiment la
question de la boulangerie par exemple
ne sont pas considérés comme des métiers
en tension dans la liste qui est établi
au niveau national on se pose un vrai
problème donc effectivement il faut
revoir cette liste des métiers en
tension qui d'ailleurs est un engagement
depuis 2019 du gouvernement cette liste
sera revue cette liste j'ai pas dit que
il y avait besoin de là pour ça cette
liste sera revue chaque année pour
justement faire en sorte que la pénurie
soit
établie chaque année pour pour les
métiers en tension et ça va nous
permettre de créer effectivement un
titre de séjour pour ces métiers en
tension et je pense aussi d'ailleurs sur
un titre de séjour que Nicolas Sarkozy
avait créé je crois c'était le titre
talent et compétences le
passeport talent pardon le passeport
talent et donc aujourd'hui on voulait
l'élargir également à tout ce qui est
métier médical tout ce qui est
paramédical et tout ce qui nous
permettra aussi d'avoir des compétences
qui étrangères que nous manquons en
France pour pallier aux pénuries de
recrutement aujourd'hui 60% des
entreprises dans notre pays ont des
difficultés de recrutement 30 % du
milieu industriel n'arrive pas à
recruter et baisse sa production pour
des raisons de recrutement donc on voit
bien qu'il y a aussi une demande du
tissu économique de pouvoir avoir une
vraie loi d'intégration on va parler de
ce sujet je vous laisse répondre sur ma
chaîne apprendre un exemple justement de
reportage on ira à Metz non mais c'est
quoi le métier qui est pas en tension
aujourd'hui donc ouvrir la liste des
métiers en tension c'est dire la France
entière est en tension enfin c'est donc
une sorte de blague et il y a pas besoin
de loi pour le faire comme il n'y a pas
besoin de loi pour revoir les pays où il
y a pas la possibilité de demander
l'asile il y a déjà beaucoup de choses
qui peuvent être faites et qui ne sont
pas faites donc le si je suis désolé
cette loi simule l'idée de on va faire
une petite dimension la vraie sujet moi
j'aurais et je suis très d'accord je
pense en vrai d'accord ensemble j'aurais
vraiment aimé une loi sur l'intégration
mais c'est exactement ça non c'est une
loi d'immigration avec excusez-moi c'est
la première fois qu'on a un volet
intégration qui est aussi important sur
les lois justement d'immigration
regardez la loi de 2018 c'était pas du
tout sur cette question là on était sur
une question plutôt d'intégration des
régulations de l'immigration là on est
sur effectivement une fermeté et un
recours aussi comment ça
réduit une réduction pardon des délais
sur les recours et sur les les
établissements des occultés
le sénateur 12 actuellement
effectivement le Conseil d'État a
préconisé en mars 2020 de réduire à 2 +
1 2 d'urgence un ordinaire aujourd'hui
on propose quatre dans ce texte pour
pallier aux 12 qui existent actuellement
donc effectivement on réduit les
délaisses ça ça doit passer par la loi
vous le savez très bien et donc on a
besoin d'avoir à la fois de la fermeté
un une réduction des délais mais aussi
quelque chose de qui intègre mieux ceux
qui sont dans notre pays et faire en
sorte aussi de sortir de l'hypocrisie de
dans laquelle nous sommes actuellement
quand on voit que un certain nombre
d'employeurs des salariés des salariés
pardon étrangers qui payent des
cotisations qui payent des impôts mais
qui aujourd'hui peuvent avoir des au qtf
puisqu'ils sont en situation irrégulière
donc il faut sortir aussi c'est
travailleurs des traps à inégalité que
certains employeurs malveillants peuvent
mettre en place donc oui effectivement
il faut sortir de l'hypocrisie pour ça
on aimerait faire crédit Xavier kovelli
de ce qu'il dit des intentions qui sont
affichées je me souviens qu'à l'époque
du texte que je proposais il y avait peu
d'ardeurs chez les macronistes pour
venir manger au secours de notre
de notre par mois pas sur la zone parle
pas sur l'aide sociale
et le drame et le drame et le drame de
du macronisme en l'espèce sur
l'immigration c'est toujours cette
dimension tactique c'est-à-dire que on a
le sentiment qu'on est à la surface des
choses très superficielles alors c'est
Gérald Darmanin qui cite Bainville de
l'Action française mais en prenant des
propos dont on pourrait penser qu'ils
ont presque de gauche c'est l'humanité
la fermeté
c'est quoi le projet c'est quoi le
projet de Monsieur Macron de Madame
borne au fond pour le pays pour la
France pour les Français qu'est-ce qu'on
attend et là on peut dire alors c'est
pas c'est pas que quatre motifs
d'expulsion c'est doute peu importe le
sujet c'est de comprendre dans le débat
politique de faire comprendre aux
Français ce qu'on attend et je pense que
on est parti comme toujours avec un coup
à droite un coup à gauche et en même
temps qui est pas tenable sur la
question de l'immigration
qu'on arrête de jouer et on peut pas
toujours être dans la tactique donc moi
j'aimerais que revanche à gauche et à
droite je crains que ça penche beaucoup
à droite notamment du fait de la
configuration de l'Assemblée nationale
on verra ce qui restera de l'humanité
une fois que la fermeté à la haine sera
passée
quand on a aujourd'hui une population
étrangère issue de l'étranger qui est un
taux de chômage à peu près à
14,8% alors que nous sommes à peu près à
7% pour pour la population née en France
on a vraiment une question aussi sur
l'intégration par le travail et donc
c'est une des mesures des mesures
portées par au lycée tout à fait donc
c'est pour ça que on pense qu'il faut
effectivement avoir une obligation
d'avoir un acquis des acquis sur le
français pour pouvoir avoir un titre de
séjour ça c'est aussi une modification
par la loi que nous voulons mettre en
place et puis par l'intégration par le
travail parce qu'on pense comme pour
toutes les mesures de la réforme du
travail que nous mettons pour les
Français nous pensons que l'intégration
par le travail et la solution pour
répondre à la fois aux besoins du tissu
économique mais aussi pour respecter
notre cadre républicain et donc nous on
pense à ça on pense que ça c'est la
meilleure méthode de l'intégration par
le travail mais aussi une fermeture peut
ceux qui n'ont pas
la France vocation ce n'est pas que le
travail mais vous avez pensé aussi le
travail mais c'est la France c'est aussi
autre chose ce sont des valeurs fortes
et une vraie vision du pays de ce que
l'on veut en faire et tant qu'on
exprimera pas qu'on sera dans le même
temps dans le simoule en latin et ça
donne simulation et bien c'est
exactement ce que l'on fait on ne sait
pas ce que l'on fait on ne peut pas
intégrer quand vous avez pas là
et comment pour intégrer les gens vous
est-ce que vous sortirez des grandes
phrases peut-être que vous pourrez nous
faire des propositions et d'ailleurs
c'est le but du débat d'aujourd'hui et
c'est le but du texte qui arrivera euh
François Noël buffet qui a fait une
proposition que je vais qualifier
dolistique de général pour traiter du
sujet et bien on nous a propositions
votre Ministre de l'Intérieur a dit que
notre milieu intérieur accessoirement
c'est de votre signe à choisi de de
s'inspirer de ce qu'elle dit Françoise
fait alors ne confondez pas donc vous ne
comprenez pas oui d'accord bah donc
nous avons fait une proposition et ben
nous attendons vos propositions qui sont
largement dévoyés je pense qu'elles ont
été largement ministre des voyeurs sur
la question du travail puisque vous
l'avez dit parmi les mesures du texte
facilité la régularisation par le
travail pour les travailleurs étrangers
dans les métiers en tension les acteurs
du secteur du bâtiment notamment
attendent beaucoup de cette mesure au
drevetage nous emmène à Metz dans une
entreprise qui croule sous les demandes
de chantier et peine pourtant à trouver
de la main d'oeuvre pour les honorer
entre la crise des énergies et les
normes européennes qui se durcissent il
n'y a jamais eu autant de demandes pour
isoler les bâtiments à Metz pfff façade
est l'un des acteurs majeurs à sa tête
David Arslan un patron qu'on imagine
comblé et pourtant il peine à recruter
le bâtiment
n'a pas forcément animal très sexy une
nouvelle génération ils ont été orientés
plutôt bas par vers d'autres métiers que
le bâtiment résultat sur la cinquantaine
de salariés de pff 80% sont des
travailleurs étrangers ou arrivés en
tant que tel on prend ce qui sont de
demandeurs et plupart des candidats sont
des immigrés et d'origine étrangère
parce que il vient de des conditions de
très difficiles et déjà ils sont
contents de trouver un travail David
Arslan a même créé sa propre école de
façadier unique en France pour former
cette main d'oeuvre étrangère si ce côté
fait 41 ans fait partie de la première
promotion il n'y connaissait rien en
bâtiment
d'avoir une place dans un travail que
j'aime bien ça me décroche la joie et la
tranquillité ce mauritanien est arrivé
en France via une procédure de
regroupement familial
David Arslan a pu le former et
l'embaucher car il a un titre de séjour
mais souvent ce n'est pas le cas le
patron doit refuser des candidatures et
de l'autre côté refuser des chantiers
faute de main d'oeuvre alors il attend
beaucoup du projet de loi immigration
qui devrait permettre d'assouplir les
régularisations dans les métiers en
tension comme le bâtiment
en France ils sont déjà sur le
territoire français il coûte l'argent à
l'état
et de l'autre côté il y a besoin de main
d'oeuvre dans les entreprises il suffit
juste de faire une connexion du côté des
associations qui aident les personnes
étrangères dans leur démarche le
sentiment est ambivalent il y a de
l'attente on est content au départ parce
qu'effectivement c'est quand même une
régularisation par le travail ça devrait
permettre de régulariser quand même un
certain nombre de dossiers mais du
scepticisme aussi entre l'esprit du
texte et la réalité de terrain toutes
les précédentes
qui apportait des aménagements
positifs
n'ont jamais été respectés depuis six
mois on a des problèmes de demande de
renouvellement c'est-à-dire ce sont des
gens qui travaillent depuis 3 5 7 8 10
12 ans mais à cause de délai de
traitement souvent trop long en
préfecture près de 40 personnes non pas
pu renouveler leur titre de séjour dans
la région elles étaient pourtant
intégrées dans des entreprises qui ont
dû les licencier
vous voyez avec cet exemple c'est un
exemple parmi d'autres évidemment un
Jérôme pas cher mais ce chef
d'entreprise qui a des chantiers qui
n'arrivent pas à les honorer parce que
il y a un manque de main d'oeuvre est-ce
que du coup cette régularisation en tout
cas c'est titre de séjour provisoire
pour les étrangers qui sont dans des
métiers en tension c'est une propose
c'est une proposition que vous pourriez
voter je ne suis pas sûr que nous
votions les régularisations c'est un
vrai sujet sur une fois que vous avez
violé la loi peut-être qu'il aurait
fallu la changer avant changeons la loi
changeons les textes et après on fait ce
qu'il faut je comprends la détresse et
moi il y a une chose qui m'a beaucoup
plus touchée dans ce reportage c'est
effectivement cet homme qui de 41 ans
qui était heureux d'être en France pour
la tranquillité et c'est ça la des vrais
promesses qu'on doit avoir et c'est ça
les réalités de l'immigration
aujourd'hui ce sont des gens malheureux
qui viennent dans notre pays chercher de
la tranquillité que ce soit quand vous
interrogez les policiers de l'air et les
frontières à Menton leur demander mais
alors qui vient et bien ce sont encore
des Irakiens c'est encore le
Moyen-Orient et c'est encore les retrait
Éthiopie assez largement qui ou la
Mauritanie ou peut pas la peine de vous
expliquer qu'on a été chassé pour
avoir des gens malheureux opprimés etc
ils viennent chercher de la tranquillité
et du travail c'est pas des gens qui
viennent je vais faire un grand
remplacement comme certains voudraient
le faire croire ce sont des gens qui
viennent travailler et dans la
tranquillité et la tranquillité c'est
cette promesse républicaine qu'il faut
maintenir et si vous ne pas en laissant
bien le modèle français républicain
d'accueil mais le modèle français
républicain alors à ce moment-là vous
recréez des ghettos des villages etc et
ça c'est pas spectacle
ce texte ne traite pas du sujet et c'est
bien ça le problème c'est une vision à
chaque fois parcellaire alors il traite
des petits bouts des petits bouts
sont positifs le passage de 12 à 3 dit
le Conseil d'État vous proposez 4 vous
voyez c'est toujours un mi-chemin en
même temps allez on va pas aller
jusqu'au bout ça serait dommage vous
n'êtes pas très bien en maths parce que
le mi-chemin entre 12 et 3 ça fait 4
sur cette question
que moi vous le saurez mais vous vous
sentez en même temps c'est ça
parler de projets de régularisation
massive est-ce que vous aussi vous êtes
sur cette ligne et en quoi c'est une
régularisation
massive mais il y aura un sujet
régularisation et donc derrière vous
avez aussi attendez je vais vous dire un
truc derrière vous avez aussi des
patrons voyous car quand vous allez sur
les dépôts de chantier dans la région
Île-de-France vous savez enfin je vais
pas citer une mais les les les ceux qui
font les matériaux et bien vous avez
tous les matins les camionnettes qui
arrivent et qui ramasse 4 5 personnes
directement qui sont là qui demande du
travail
tout le buté alors si c'est pour
régulariser et faciliter les patrons
voyous je n'en serais pas sur cette
proposition
oui je pense qu'il faut il faut
dissiper toute crainte dans la
population sur le fait que à la faveur
des flux migratoires on est des gens mal
intentionnés qui viennent chez nous
alors les gens qui les méchants c'est
évident c'est évident c'est-à-dire que
un état comme la France un pays comme la
France peut pas supporter d'avoir des
gens qui se comportent mal mais une fois
qu'on a dit ça on n'a rien dit et je
pense que surtout au fond il faut qu'on
transforme la peur en confiance
c'est-à-dire que est-ce qu'on est un
pays d'intégration est-ce qu'on en a les
moyens est-ce qu'on souhaite est-ce
qu'on veut vraiment permettre des
parcours à des personnes voilà que poser
ces questions au fond avant d'être ce
que disait tout à l'heure à la surface
des choses et il me semble que un des
enjeux c'est c'est de d'arrêter le
gâchis votre reportage le montre très
bien on a des gens dans ce pays qui se
sont engagés dans des voies
professionnalisantes qui ont trouvé des
employeurs qui pour des problèmes
administratifs parce que ça coince dans
les préfectures parce que il y a des
dispositif arbitraire aussi chez les
préfets qui sont obligés des fois de
faire un peu la politique du chiffre
conduit à prononcer des occupésf contre
des personnes qu'on ne pourra pas
exécuter parce qu'on n'a pas les laisser
passer consulaires en marchant à la tête
et une demande de travail une offre de
travail on arrive pas à rapprocher les
deux pour de sombres histoires
administratives donc ça si le texte
permet de résoudre ça on aura bien
travaillé et je le dis pour les
socialistes au cela nous quand les
textes sont intelligents qui vont au
bout des choses on n'est pas dans
l'idéologie sur la loop me on nous
attendait pas sur un vote favorable on a
voté pour parce qu'on considère que 15
milliards pour les forces de sécurité
intérieurs c'est intéressant donc sur
l'immigration c'est la même chose mais à
condition qu'on sorte de de cette
rhétorique un peu facile gentil méchant
et puis qu'on se pose des questions au
fond quid quand même de l'intérêt des
pays d'origine si c'est pour aller
pomper les cerveaux si c'est pour aller
vider un certain nombre de pays de leur
cadre non et puis des parcours
vous êtes prêt à écouter ça vous avez
covidie pour trouver un compromis avec
les socialistes on parlera avec
l'ensemble des oppositions enfin c'est
le but de la concertation que nous
menons sur sur ce texte et du débat
qu'en aura tout à l'heure donc moi je
voudrais répondre sur deux points
effectivement sur la question des
employeurs voyous que sénateurs a
indiqué effectivement il y a aujourd'hui
des sanctions qui sont prévues dans le
dans le code c'est à dire 5 ans
d'emprisonnement 15000 euros d'amende
sauf qu'on voit bien qu'il y a 500
procédures par an qui sont lancés et
sans sanctions qui sont réellement
appliquées par an donc pour qu'une
sanction elle soit utile il faut qu'elle
soit appliquée et donc on voit bien
qu'on a besoin aussi de renforcer un
certain nombre de dispositifs pour
lutter contre les employeurs qui
utilisent cette trappes à illégalité et
puis il y a aussi ce que je le disais
tout à l'heure sortir de l'hypocrisie il
y a je rejoins Jérôme Durin sur sur
cette question là on a des travailleurs
aujourd'hui qui ont qui sont embauchés
avec un titre de séjour et un problème
administratif de renouvellement du titre
de séjour il perdent leur titre de
séjour parfois même les employeurs ne se
rendent pas compte donc eux-mêmes se
mettent en difficulté administrative et
notamment sur la restauration on a vu un
certain nombre de restaurants fermés
administrativement pour des problèmes de
renouvellement des titres de séjour donc
on a besoin de simplifier les démarches
que ça soit rattaché non plus à
l'employeur mais bien aux salariés et
donc ça c'est toutes les l'enjeu du
texte également et puis il y a aussi la
question des demandeurs d'asile on sait
très bien qu'un order d'asile lorsqu'il
vient d'Afghanistan par exemple il y a
99% de chances que il est un titre de
séjour en tant que réfugiés et donc lui
permettre aujourd'hui de travailler plus
rapidement que le délai qui peut courir
entre 6 mois et un an l'instruction de
son dossier ça va aussi pour une
meilleure intégration on l'a fait pour
les Ukrainiens on a fait en sorte
d'avoir un titre spécifique pour les
ukrainiens et donc l'idée c'est de faire
en sorte que sur ces pays où on est
quasi sûr que que on leur donnera un
titre de séjour qui puisse pouvoir
travailler rapidement c'est tout l'enjeu
en fait de l'intégration par le travail
qui est aujourd'hui portée dans ce texte
cette réforme de préfecture pour le
schématiser ça va dans le bon sens
clarifier ce
mails administratif pour qu'on puisse
avoir plus de fluidité et puis permettre
à ceux qui travaillent de continuer à
travailler et ceux qui ont envie de
travailler de s'intégrer et
je pense vraiment aussi que ça pose la
question sortir de l'hypocrisie des
plateformes bien sûr on connaît quand
même la situation des travailleurs dans
les plateformes qui sont essentiellement
des personnes étrangères centres de
séjour qui travaillent dans des
conditions épouvantables là il y a une
présomption de salariat il faut aussi
qu'on avance sur ce sujet qui est un
sujet induit par les questions qu'on
pose en matière d'asile immigration
prévu aussi dans le texte notamment sur
le recours du travail indépendant qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas régulier sur la
nationalité et donc sur le titre de
séjour donc on a aussi besoin de lutter
contre effectivement
ces trois à illégalité ces trappes à
précarité aussi pour un certain nombre
de travailleurs des plateformes
est-ce que vous pourriez voter ce texte
il faudrait aussi aller un peu plus
parce que il y a pas que de l'angélisme
à faire il faut pour que le texte soit
bien compris bien accepté de l'ensemble
des conseils ne pas laisser comme dit
Madame borne à l'extrême droite le
monopole de hurler sans arrêt et des
bons et des méchants comme dit Jérôme du
Rhin c'est d'avoir d'être aussi
fort sur l'immigration illégale sur le
contrôle des papiers on a aujourd'hui un
énorme défaut sur les papiers et il y a
une fraude documentaire notamment sur
les papiers étrangers qui est colossal
colossal demandez aux grèves des
tribunaux de commerce je suis allé voir
je vous explique que l'essentiel des
leurs déclarations à trac fin à la
gendarmerie etc porte sur des papiers
étrangers donc on nous avons aussi des
sujets à traiter là dessus c'est
extrêmement important et puis un sujet
dont on ne parle pas c'est que et vous
avez des demandeurs d'asile la demande
de travail mais vous avez et aussi le
regroupement familial qui est aussi une
grosse partie et ça ce n'est pas
l'intégration par le travail c'est un
vrai sujet qu'il faut aussi traiter
aujourd'hui tant que vous n'êtes pas
parfaitement intégré est-ce que vous
pouvez intégrer votre famille c'est une
vraie question c'est pour moi un sujet
aujourd'hui il y a dans le problème
d'intégration c'est que l'essentiel des
départements qui accueillent
l'immigration
et bien ce sont les déjà les
départements que j'ai qualifiés de
saturer en termes d'intégration c'est
pas normal que ce soit la
Seine-Saint-Denis on peut dire les
choses en français le département de
Seine qui attire qui dans lequel il y a
le plus d'accueil or c'est déjà le pays
le plus c'est-à-dire saturé donc pour
bien intégrer dans le modèle républicain
français il faut aussi pouvoir avoir la
bonne dose et aujourd'hui ça veut dire
qu'il faut aussi répartir comme le dit
Emmanuel Macron il y a forcément un
sujet de répartition et moi j'habite
assez près d'un cadavre j'étais assez
choqué de voir quand loi Atlantique que
certains manifestaient contre un cadavre
honnêtement ça serait si c'était là où
il y avait le plus d'illégalités merci
Monsieur on suivra bien sûr Elisabeth
borne et le débat de vent le Sénat ce
sera à partir de 17h30 sur notre antenne
vous restez avec nous on regarde ce
qu'elle a une de nos quotidiens
régionaux
[Musique]